What's up everyone?
This week we are celebrating
3 Million subscribers on YouTube!
And so to thank you we have a highly
requested lesson today,
and we are going to be learning English
with this book.
We'll be learning with Harry Potter and
The Philosopher's Stone.
The first book in the series by J.K Rowling,
and in the first part of today's lesson
i'm going to be reading a few
of the pages
and then in the second part i'm going to
teach you the trickiest pieces of
vocabulary.
So I recommend you grab yourself a cup
of tea, coffee or hot chocolate,
whatever it is
you fancy and you join me in this very
special lesson.
By the way, if you want to understand
fast English without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and
without subtitles, then make sure you
hit that Subscribe button and the Bell
down below, so that you don't miss
any of our new lessons. Just like this
fan who says that our channel is amazing
and the best English teaching
channel out there.
Now, if you'd like to read along with me
I'm going to be reading
chapter 6, from page 111.
Okay, so now we're going to take a look
at some of the tricky vocabulary in this passage.
So here at Learn English
with TV Series we are celebrating
3 Million subscribers. Thanks to you we
have been able to help
many more people learn English all
around the world.
So to say thank you, you can get a 51%
discount of our Fluent with Friends course,
just for the next few days.
Just imagine, this time next year you
could be having a meaningful
conversation,
you could be moving to another country,
you could even get a promotion
at work, and you can be watching your
favorite tv series and movies
laughing at all the jokes. The possibilities
are endless when you put
your mind to it.
And our Fluent with Friends course can
really help you on your journey.
Just like Jenny, who says that with each
passing day she now realizes that she's
learned
new words or phrases that she can put
into practice,
and that English can be fun and
enjoyable.
So what are you waiting for to learn
more you can click up here or down in
the description box below,
and to get your 51% discount all you have
to do is use 3million at checkout.
Fabulous work today guys! I hope you
enjoyed this highly requested lesson
and very special one too. So if you're
ready to take your English to the next
level and start understanding your
favorite TV series
and movies, then I highly recommend
you take advantage
and check out our Fluent with Friends
course for that huge
discount of 51% off.
All you have to do is use the code
3million at checkout.
And you can click up here or down in the
description box below
to check that out and sign up now.
But do remember you only have a few more
days to
take advantage of this huge discount an
amazing offer.
So now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and
live your English.
Aww yeah!